joining us right now one of my favorite
guests Pro Football Hall of Famer and
NFL on Fox analysts just see him Sundays
and you'll see him on Thursdays - this
season is Fox's Thursday Night Football
as soon as NBC's done with it this week
he's Howie long how are you how I I'm
good how are you I'm doing great we're
how to jump in with you man there's so
many different ways to go with this
conversation well where am I where are
you
Philadelphia okay see you there just got
done watching our grandson is a grandson
going to game than others it start too
late you know the night games just too
late he's uh two-and-a-half he's a
little stuck bolt but easier kind of
turns into like most kids that are
two-and-a-half around 10:30 11 o'clock
they just kind of they start to dissolve
yeah it makes sense then so just have
somebody give him a look-see and after
putting him down and then the whole
family can watch Chris have at it
tonight for the Eagles what do you think
of the Eagles chances to repeat Howie
what the analysts had on there well no I
heard what you said and I you know I
think if history tells us anything it's
it's extremely difficult first you know
you've got to retain the people on your
roster as best you can
which is always a challenge following a
Super Bowl I think having the luxury
that Seattle had with Russel Wilson the
Rams have a God and the Philadelphia
Eagles have with once where you're
dealing with a quarterback on the rookie
contract which allows you to luxury in
the Rams er they're taking full
advantage of it at this point I mean who
haven't they tried to sign I I thought I
heard them they signed Butkus yesterday
pretty much yeah on the two two-week
contract just to scare the living hell
out of people for the first two games
but you know that's one and they did a
good job with that they did a good job
of retaining their talent
brought in some pieces from outside it
gives them the luxury of continuity new
offensive coordinator new quarterback
coach those two things are are different
unique I think you know I people were
optimistically hoping that Carson would
be ready for week one but you know Nick
Foles I don't put much into the
preseason you're not game planning they
didn't have their full complement of
players out there on the field
protection wasn't great and and I
thought Kelsey put it down he said if we
do our job Nick will do his job and and
here's a guy that gets on a run historic
run towards the end of the season and
into the playoffs and I don't think it's
heart rate at over 60 I it it's mind
boggling how well he played and how what
an extraordinary season it was said I'm
right down to the parade and the Kelsey
speech and you know the whole thing was
amazing but now comes 2018 and health
and hunger or the two things
can you stay healthy now they overcame a
lot of injuries last year can they stay
relatively healthy this year
can they get Carson back and now how
hungry are you after the parade and the
banquets and the Pat's on the back and
you know the key to the city because you
got to remember there's a city that
never won a Super Bowl winning here is
unique it's kind of like winning in
Chicago you know the 85 Bears won there
and you know still to this day it almost
seems like that 85 Bears team was
yesterday Howie Long hall-of-famer here
on the Rich Eisen show and yet you know
you take a look across state and that
appears to be where a lot of the
attention is of the NFL media going into
this opening night not in Philadelphia
particularly but in Pittsburgh where
levy on bail is still holding out or at
least not signing his franchise tender
so he's holding his services
let's put it that way and his offensive
linemen were very critical of him not
showing up yesterday a rare public spat
between players as it seems over money I
wonder what you think of this how he
long well one of them was a player rep
which reminds yeah you know what
well tell you that just sounds like
something's amiss there doesn't it rich
it does um particularly with offensive
linemen these are you know generally
they're they're solid guys they're our
SWAT guys they kind of they're like
cattle they travel together for them to
step out and make those kind of comments
it gives you kind of a glimpse inside
that maybe there's something more going
on there than than meets the eye because
typically when a players you know don't
mess with my family or my money and you
know supporting your teammates efforts
to you know III was interesting that
none of the comments were directed
towards the organization I have my own
feelings about two things one in a
league where the average career is three
and a half years right you're a
first-round picks on a four-year
contract with an option for a fifth year
but the team has to opt into after year
three they opt into it after year three
you think well okay you're five
guaranteed not really because after your
four in march they can opt out of your
five but if they want to opt them into
your five they can have you for your
five franchises your sex and franchises
your seven in a league where the average
career is three and a half years now if
your franchise tag it's like Rich Eisen
your contracts up let's say Fox makes
you an offer that's double the money
that you could get where you are now
sold I'm sorry this thing out I'm sorry
but your current employer is saying
no right we're gonna pay you the average
of the top five people at your position
not last year but over the last five
years how bizarre is that so that's
that's why a lot of people how he had
how he longed here in the Rich Eisen
show eyebrows raised when as you pointed
the first thing you said spoken like by
the way a guy who's been through two
player strikes as you you did that one
of the guys who spoke out Ramon Foster
is a player rep he's the rep the
Steelers to the NFL Players Association
talking about this money is that a lot
of people think that this is indicative
of the problem the players are gonna
have when the CBA gets renegotiated in
three years now do you think that or or
what meet can you put on the bones of
what you think could be behind the
scenes here well I in my mind something
has to change I mean we're talking about
there's a lot of talk about abbreviating
the preseason schedule I mean you know
what we're exposing our players to but
we want to add two more games that
season I'm not quite following you the
logic there because in the preseason I'm
getting ten snaps on I'm sitting on my
helmet okay mmm-hmm but if we extend the
season regardless if we expand the
rosters how is expanding the roster
going to impact let's say a healthy JJ
Watt or an a healthy Aaron Donald
because Aaron Donald's gonna play every
snap they could possibly plan the
dominant player is Khalil Mac they're
going to be there in every situation
just because you've up the roster all
that really does those players that
you're upping your roster with are
impact players in terms of yeah depth
but it's mostly special teams so it
really doesn't impact the left tackle
who's now playing 18 foldings
or the offensive guard is playing 18
full games so I you know there are
challenges on many levels the collective
bargain agreement impacts the salary
structure in years of contra
for rookies how long you can keep a
veteran in terms of franchise tech
franchise tech transition Ted do you
think though what's we're seeing this
out this bickering or calling out of a
teammate is indicative of players will
when push comes to shove rubber meeting
Road not be able to strike a deal to get
out of it's not just agony et cetera
which I think the situation is a unique
situation I'm not inside Pittsburgh
Steeler locker room I'm not familiar
with the relationships but something's
amiss there particularly for a running
back to offensive lineman to be critical
now some of those comments were and I
think if you're if you're going to be
totally honest and give a complete kind
of perspective of what was said play the
whole soundbite because there were a
number of comments leading up to that
that word Shenton generally supportive
but then the comment but at the end of
the day if you know why are you letting
your agent do this or do that why be a
man and let us know where you stand so
it's you know I think it's a it's an
anomaly really it's a unique situation
you didn't hear that what Cleo Mac you
didn't hear that with Aaron Donald well
then let me get to that before before we
have to say odd you hear and get you off
to the game tonight dude that was epic
like goodbye and yeah I don't know why I
went French on you their house I don't
know why I did that
I think I flunked that class twice that
came from
so the khalil Mac trade what do you
think is going on in that Raiders locker
room right now prior to the season with
all that has happened there one it was a
shock to me I'm not in the organization
or in the locker room right but you know
when John comes in and signs a 10-year
contract John's in charge of course Marc
signs off I mean you know at the end of
the day Marcus
is the guy but it's John's vision on the
field and you want to support that and
from what I gather Khalil is a great
player I think he's a generational
player I think he's on the trajectory to
be potentially a Hall of Famer if he
continues to play at the level that he's
playing at that being said they felt
like if we sign Khalil to this kind of a
deal because the numbers just kept going
up but they had let's say they were able
to work something out in February or
March that would have been different but
you can't really tell where the market
goes and I think Aaron set the market
and he had it for like what was it 33
hours yeah he did it was real quick no I
guess it was like I think was like 33
hours so if you sign Khalil to that kind
of deal
beating Aaron's deal in the Raiders mind
you're handcuffed in terms of free
agency for the next two years I look at
it a little bit differently that if
you're factoring in the salary cap going
up 10 million a year and both his salary
and car salary I think it would account
for around 20 21 percent of their salary
cap each year given that the caps going
up 10 million a year you know I'm of the
mindset that you you keep a guy like
that but you know what John has a vision
and really what it comes down to what do
you do with the free agent dollars and
what do you do with those draft picks
you got Howie if if you're successful
with that that's the success if you're
not it didn't well now I know
and that so again though he's got he's
remade the roster it's 20 it's it's over
the age of 27 on average and and then
you're telling that veteran laid in
locker room that our best players now on
the Bears right now we couldn't pay them
even though they guarantee dollars is
less than mine it's a tough sell as you
know I mean it's football players are
very resilient you've got a job to do
and whether kahlil's there are not
it's your job to go play football and
win football games and compete at a high
level and if you don't do that you're
not gonna have a job that's just the way
it works it's your business is not very
different from football hmm did you have
makeup last one for you how I've been
having my phone callers and I'm gonna
phone callers if you're out there it's
still you are if hang on we'll take your
calls in this hour for Super Bowl
predictions do you got one for me how we
long oh boy if I don't pick the Eagles I
think I'll be in trouble okay so I'll
have to go homer with Eagles and you
know despite the perceived soap opera
and turnover and roster and receivers
and the offensive lines and disarray and
etc etc etc who goes to the Super Bowl
every other year New England okay so
rematch of the Super Bowl yeah in
Atlanta
okay Howie look forward to it exciting
for the call always law always enjoy our
chats enjoy the game tonight and have a
great time mike Mayock he just relaxing
on a sofa somewhere well actually I
think he's probably evaluating whatever
he's doing somebody who ever liked he
you know what he's doing he's
lollygaggin he's he is or he's probably
it was funny I got a I got a great here
let me just call it up right here there
was a great week I got you know what
he's doing he's evaluating a Pop Warner
team from Doyle town let me read this to
you I love it I love it there was a
great tweet I got from from a viewer a
listener that they went shopping and the
the the the jeans were high waist ankle
breaker and somebody tweeted that to me
saying it sounded like a Mayock
evaluation during the combine it sounded
just like that bike bike is the best he
is he's my kids love Mike they can do
imitations of Mike we can all of us hey
how are you take care hey have a great
one and let's have a great season I look
forward to let's chat during the
Thursday night football season let's do
it all right partner
okay that's how
long hall of famer here in the Rich
Eisen show the Rich Eisen show weekdays
at noon eastern on audience